At first glance, a kangaroo's pouch
looks like nothing but
a built-in baby sling.
But if you peeked inside,
you'd see it's far more
complex than a simple pocket.
It has to be, because the joey inside
is not your average baby.
An adult male red kangaroo can stand over
1 1/2 meters tall and weigh 90 kilograms.
That's larger than a grown man.
But the newborns start out
the size of jelly beans.
They're blind, deaf, and hairless to boot.
After all, they only spend 33 days
inside their mom before birth.
That's like a human having a baby
when she's two months pregnant.
So the underdeveloped
roo isn't ready to face
the harsh Australian wilderness.
That's where the pouch comes in.
It's a pocket of skin that
acts like a second womb,
giving the joey a safe,
cozy environment to grow.
And, like a pregnant belly,
the pouch can stretch to fit
the baby as it gets bigger.
It's lined with powerful,
but flexible, muscles and ligaments.
To keep the joey safe, mom
can tighten those muscles
to shut the pouch flush against her body,
just like pulling a drawstring bag closed.
And it will need the extra space,
because over the course of eight months,
that bean-sized baby will reach the size
of a large house cat.
That's thousands of
times its birth weight.
That rapid growth is thanks
to the pouch's four nipples,
which spout milk that contains
germ-fighting antibodies
to keep the little roo from getting sick.
But that's just the start.
You see, the nutrient levels change
to meet the baby's needs as it ages.
For example, sulfur, a major
building block of hair,
peaks around three months in.
That's the same time the
baby starts growing fur.
The best part?
Mom can produce multiple types
of milk at the same time,
each squirting from its own nipple.
So she can suckle two babies
in different age groups simultaneously.
Another special feature
about the kangaroo pouch
is that it's lined with sweat glands
that release antimicrobial substances,
which help protect the baby roos
from harmful viruses,
bacteria, and parasites.
But there's one more
way that pouch's design
keeps the joey safe.
It's totally hairless, and
that skin-to-skin contact
keeps the baby warm and cozy.
Basically, it's the ultimate nursery.
But nothing lasts forever.
Eventually, the joey will
need to leave the pouch.
At about 5 months old,
it pokes its head out.
And a month later, it
takes its first tentative
steps into the world.
There, it will explore
for a few short seconds
before high-tailing it home.
But as it gets older and
bolder, it stays out longer,
until eight months in:
It's ready to leave the nest,
well, the pouch, for good.